you're not a person
you're a planet
made of roughly 40 trillion cells
there is so much of you that if your
cells were human sized you'd be as big
as 20 mount everest
for your creepy crawly inhabitants this
makes your body an ecosystem rich in
resources and warmth and space a perfect
place to move into and have a family
while some of these guests are welcome
most are not your immune system is the
guardian of this planet the force tasked
with protecting yourself against the
constant danger of invasion
unfortunately your enemies in the tiny
world have a huge advantage
[Music]
consider the effort it takes to make a
single copy of yourself and your
trillions of cells
first you need to find someone who
thinks you're cute date and be awkward
and if things work out in a complicated
dance two of your cells merge together
then you need to wait for months while
the cell multiplies over and over until
it's released into the world as a human
being
and even then you only have a mini copy
that needs years to become remotely
useful
a bacterium consists of one cell it can
make a fully grown copy in about half an
hour
a virus can turn into hundreds within
hours and billions within days
your enemies multiply orders of
magnitude faster than you even worse for
a bacterium or virus your body is a
hostile ecosystem applying selective
pressure
because they go through so many
generations so quickly eventually by
pure chance there will be an individual
that mutates and adapts in just the
right way to resist your defenses and
then multiply quickly again in other
words you're facing a sheer endless
variety of different enemies and you're
too slow to keep up with their evolution
this is bad
luckily your immune system is just about
the most amazing thing ever
the second most complex biological
system known to us after the human brain
and so sophisticated that we still
haven't discovered all its secrets since
it's so complicated we have to simplify
and focus on one thing at a time if you
want the full story wait for the
announcement at the end of the video
okay so why are we not all killed by
some new bacteria or virus
in a nutshell you actually have two
immune systems the innate and the
adaptive immune system
the innate immune system was ready when
you were born
it mostly consists of general purpose
soldiers we introduced them in the last
immune video
the adaptive immune system carries two
types of cells t-cells and b-cells that
are your super weapons and are
incredibly effective and deadly for your
enemies
these cells are complicated to produce
and take a lot of time to deploy but
once they're ready they pack a real
punch
what makes your adaptive immune system
so powerful is that it has the largest
library in the universe it has an answer
to everything
you have at least one of these super
weapon cells inside you to fight the
black death the coronavirus and the
first deadly bacteria that will emerge
in a city on mars in 100 years
this makes it possible for you to
counter the ability of bacteria and
viruses to change so rapidly
how is this possible
to understand what's going on here we
need to take one step back
all organisms on earth are made from the
same basic parts mostly proteins
proteins are the building blocks of life
and can have billions of different
shapes you can imagine them as 3d puzzle
pieces
there are billions of different puzzle
pieces your enemies can use to construct
their bodies
why is this important
because proteins are in a way the
language of the micro world
cells don't have eyes or ears so to tell
friend from foe they have to touch them
and recognize if their protein is part
of a friend or part of an enemy
recognizing means that cells have
countless tiny devices called receptors
that are able to connect with a specific
protein puzzle piece
so your cells have tiny puzzle pieces on
their outsides that are able to click
together or recognize other protein
puzzle pieces when a cell connects
together with a protein and recognizes
it as enemy it knows that it has to
attack
only if your cells can make this
distinction between friend or foe is
your immune system able to fight an
invader
but since there are billions of possible
protein puzzle pieces this means there
are billions of possible enemy puzzle
pieces
this is also one of the reasons we still
have to deal with diseases like the flu
each year the influenza virus mutates
very rapidly and so the proteins that
make up its hull constantly change a
tiny bit
the soldiers of your innate immune
system have a large number of the puzzle
pieces for common bacteria and viruses
memorized that's why they are your
all-purpose weapons
but they are ineffective against many
billions of mutations and adaptations
that your enemies can develop
so the reason you are still alive is
that your adaptive immune system is able
to recognize between 1 billion and 10
billion different enemy protein puzzle
pieces which is enough to be prepared
for every possible enemy
but how is this possible
how could your immune system possibly
have this much of a variety to be
prepared for every possible protein
puzzle piece
well the cells of your adaptive immune
system found a cheat code
mixing and matching their own genetic
code to create this stunning variety of
receptors
the details are way too complicated for
this video but in a nutshell your
adaptive immune cells have official
permission to take a tiny part of their
own genetic code and mix it in random
ways to create billions of different
receptors
a good way to explain this is by asking
you to imagine an army of cooks with
each of them wanting their own special
recipe
they have 100 different ingredients to
choose from
each ingredient stands for one tiny
piece of genetic code in this metaphor
so each cook takes a few random
ingredients and randomly mixes them
together maybe tomato chicken rice and
half an onion as entree marshmallow
pepper strawberries and a quarter banana
as a dessert
or cucumber beef potatoes and two
carrots and blueberries chocolate and
cream with a pinch of cinnamon
even with slight variation and with only
100 ingredients there are billions of
possible recipes
and likewise with just a small selection
of gene fragments your cells create
billions of receptors
the details of this are so cool that
they should get their own video or their
own chapter in a book
in any case by mixing up gene fragments
you get up to 10 billion different
combinations
so in the end you get billions of immune
cells and each of them has one specific
and unique receptor the dish from our
metaphor that is able to recognize one
specific protein puzzle piece
in total you end up with at least one
cell for every enemy that could possibly
exist but here we run into a pretty
dangerous problem if your adaptive
immune system is making weapons that can
attack every possible protein puzzle
piece in the universe wouldn't it also
make some that can attack your own cells
yes it happens all the time
this is so fundamentally dangerous to
your survival that you have a whole
organ that does nothing but work on
preventing this
the murder university of your thymus
your thymus is a chicken wing-sized
organ above your heart and you've
probably never heard of it
interestingly your thymus is one of the
reasons why your immune system weakens
as you age because it's in a constant
state of decline once you reach puberty
but what does the thymus do
in your murder university your immune
system is putting your adaptive immune
cells through an intense and deadly
curriculum
basically it's showing them all sorts of
protein puzzle pieces that are used by
your own cells to see how they react
when a young cell recognizes a body
puzzle piece and wants to attack it the
teachers cells order them to kill
themselves and they are eaten up and
recycled
the immune system is so particular about
this process that around 98 of your
adaptive immune cells that enter murder
university die there
two percent graduate and get to do their
job of protecting you for real
if this process goes wrong and the cells
escape that can recognize your own
protein puzzle pieces this can lead to
autoimmune disease where your immune
system attacks your own body from the
inside
and this again is another story for
another time
okay let's summarize
your immune system has two parts one
that defends you right after birth and
one that carries the largest library of
super weapons in the universe but needs
to boot up first
to create billions of different super
weapons your adaptive immune cells
recombine a part of their genetic code
to create a breathtaking variety of
attack weapons
then they enter a murder university that
only two percent survive to make sure
they don't attack you and then you end
up with billions of different cells that
in total are able to protect you against
every possible enemy in the universe
now wait a second if this is all true
why do we get sick at all
why was a new disease like covert 19
able to kill millions of people
and how do vaccines boost the mechanisms
we explained in this video to
supercharge your immune system and
defend you from the worst diseases
humanity has ever encountered from
smallpox to covet 19.
well everything we've just learned about
is a tiny tiny window into the amazing
struggle for life and death that plays
out every day inside your body and there
are so many amazing details and
questions here
how does your body actually find the
right cell in time to protect you
how do your enemies fight back and
overcome your immune system anyway
and what about all the things that
didn't fit in this video
well today finally marks the release of
immune a journey into the mysterious
system that keeps you alive written by
philip detmer the founder and head
writer of courts first we had to push
the release back because of cargo
trouble and then because so many of you
pre-ordered that we didn't have enough
copies for the original launch day thank
you so so much for that
immune tells the epic story of your
immune system and will forever change
how you think about your own body how
you experience being sick and healthy
the book is written to be as fun and
easy to grasp as koski's art videos but
is able to dive way deeper into its
subjects so go on a journey through the
hidden microverse within yourself
witness deadly wars between billions of
invaders and cells learn how your immune
system actually works and protects you
from cuts cancer and covet
never before have we so urgently needed
to learn about how immunity works
immune is fun and great to look at and
it even smells good
follow the link in the description to
order it today
this is the end of a decade-long
personal journey working on this so
thank you all so so much for your
support and thank you for watching and
reading
[Music]
you